my ultimate comfort food dinner is a
stunning sausage hot pot which will
serve with a gorgeous potato and
beetroot gratin
now i love hot pot you love hot pot
and you love sausages right yeah
what do you enjoy most about sausages
um i just love having them
with the baked beans sometimes with
baked beans sometimes these are
little button mushrooms okay you just
take them into there like that
and keep them whole and cut them into
quarters please
now the important thing about cooking
sausages is they need a bit of color
right no color no flavor exactly get the
pan
nice and hot
how was school today school was good
thanks we got to go out and make snowmen
sausages in
okay butter mushrooms in there please
[Music]
see
now
i want you to wash your fingers but you
know how to slice onions right
definitely i'll be good right now
sausages
are getting lots of color because this
is going to cook slowly
and it's sort of daddy's version of
the kind of hot pot the other one nani's
to make for me yeah once you've got the
color on them
and take them out
to rest okay
a little normal butter okay into the pan
now it looks like a lot of onions right
yeah as they start sweating down they
caramelize
so that will go down by half
give that a little fry
okay
salt in
i want you to put a nice tablespoon of
brown sugar in there that gets them
really nice and dark now get your thyme
in
pick off all the little buds
that will get the onions
packed with flavor
that's kind of nice nice mushrooms in
give them a nice little stir
did you like to help them make your hot
pot when she made them for you i used to
always help them make the hot pot
always
now my mum would never have used this
but a's balsamic vinegar brings out the
flavor of the onions right now look at
her onions
look beautifully caramelized
the vinegar has given that nice sort of
gloss i'm going to put my sausages back
in here now from there
some red wine
red wine end
got the flavor underneath there
going into the sausages now the sausage
is going to release all that flavor
inside as well look at the color of that
does that look pretty cool
and it's still not cooked yet up to the
ball really important to boil it here
because it won't boil in the oven
170
in the oven literally
18 to 20 minutes then she goes
nice
to go with my hot pot rich golden creamy
potato gratin it's a true comfort food
classic and i'm adding a delicious twist
beetroot
start by gently heating double cream
[Music]
then peel and thinly slice potatoes and
cook beetroot
next rub garlic around the edge of your
dish to thoroughly season with a
glorious flavor then grease with a good
layer of butter
arrange alternate layers of potato
and beetroot
seasoning in between
end with a neat layer of potatoes
and pour the hot cream over the top
bake in a preheated oven for an hour or
until the potatoes are tender
[Music]
potato and beetroot greton are bubbling
beauty of a comfort food dish
now for the apple compote what we need
to do first is to get these peeled
and sliced
i get my pan on to get nice and hot now
let me give you a little taste of that
is this thanks for the warning
you're both so well only blew my head
off
they're incredibly acidic
okay and you need to cook them those
wonderful red apples you've got are
called brae burns what other apples do
you know green ones what they called um
i'm not too sure what the green one is
another word for your nan
grandmas no
red no
pink lady apple no
granny smith granny smith apples that's
right
what we're gonna do
is cook the cooking apples
and
the eating apples together
i love the combination of the tartness
from the brambley cooking apple with the
sweetness of the braeburn get the pan
nice and hot
and sprinkle the bottom of the pan
with caster sugar
three or four nice slices of fresh
ginger
and three little cinnamon sticks i want
you to remember that because we're gonna
look for them
okay because once we've used them and
they've worked their magic i need to
pull them out see all the sugar
dissolving
definitely now we just let that go a
little bit darker
okay
and then
the place
doesn't it
give that
a nice
little
toss
okay nice golden color cinnamon in
ginger in so
we're cooking down the apples
butter in
gently cook until the apples soften then
take off the heat
and we go into there what's that coming
out dab so that is a little bit of the
puree i'll show we'll do that in a
minute how many ginger
four four ginger
and three cinnamon three cinnamon out
with the cinnamon
we've got other ginger gingers i'm gonna
take
a spoon
of apples
it smells so nice how nice is that look
see the colory apples
let's put these in the fridge to get
nice and cold
that's the compost sorted easy now a
simple creamy whip to crown the top
do you separate the egg whites into
there for daddy
all right egg whites are in they're
great separate
off
[Music]
and i'll sprinkle the sugar in and then
you turn up the speed
[Applause]
good girl
[Music]
please now let's see if you've got a
really nice stiff peak so you lift them
up
now that is what i call a nice stiff
peak well done not bad not bad
next in a separate bowl whip double
cream until stiff
nice and slowly
so cream whips so much quicker
yeah
nice we're gonna
put some delicious lemon zest
which will make the cream
so much better then sweeten it up with
leftover caramely compot puree
you mix that in nice and carefully
so it's like this apple
butterscotch now to make the cream even
lighter fold in those whisked egg whites
and sugar
egg whites
into the cream
just
nicely fold that
in so you bring your glasses back out
manage the glasses yep
good girl
silly we're on for a treat
open up the piping bag
now twist the end
now you could spoon this in but i want
to just give a nice little lift it also
gives it a nice pattern
lemon on top
back in the fridge
the beetroot and potato gratin
is that lovely that's lovely
sausages
finished with the flat leaf parsley
wow look at those two beauties
it doesn't get any more comforting than
that does it for one of the best hot
pots
ever tilly that looks amazing
i know well done
this is my ultimate comfort food dinner
sausage hot pot with potato and beetroot
gratin followed by apple compote
food with guaranteed feel-good factor
there's one person who knows all about
being thrifty in the home kitchen it's
my mum god i love you i love you too
now you're gonna help me cook dinner and
give me some valuable tips on how to
save money in the home kitchen right i
will do you will do excellent see easy
peasy
[Music]
for my ultimate thrifty dinner we're
gonna make an amazing spicy braised
oxtail followed by a deliciously juicy
pudding chilli poached pears with star
and east us
now oxtail was something that we grew up
with yeah there's something you can do
in the morning and put it in the oven
because it has to be cooked really
really slow yes i'm gonna dust this in
flour it's amazing
how many chefs are using oxtail on their
menus today it's incredible this is very
popular it's very cheap as well
it's amazing i used to make it stretch
for like five or six dinners oh don't
exactly it's not that bad now i know why
we're all so skinny growing up
it wasn't that bad i'm joking come on
you know i'm joking you see
sometimes we went to the beaches and you
had maybe extra two or three i used to
put in a saucepan and you had lovely
stock for
soup what was that spicy soup that
really nice mulligatory
tony and i used to make the good pot of
scotch broth scotch broth i remember now
i'll peel a couple of cloves of garlic
i'll show you a quick word getting that
out get your knife and just
brush it nice
no it's not a mess
just peel them and i'll crush them in
the garlic crusher okay
all right oxtail in
i'm gonna fry that off we can get that
nice and brown
and we've all braised it in red wine and
sort of chicken stock before but i'm
gonna get this done with a chinese
influence the chinese absolutely love
cooking oxtail
you started cooking at home quite early
on right 17 and a half 17 and a half
your mum died quite young very young 26
26 so who taught you how to cook
not to talk to you i think you just
learn as you get older
and you learn by your mistakes and did
you enjoy it yes i did enjoy it yeah
that was a nice vegetable the fennel
panel isn't it that lovely it's
beautiful yeah a lot of people don't use
it a lot of them use it in salads but no
one actually cooks it you just slice
that up them
now these are nice and brown
they look lovely put the color on there
you just slice up the chili okay just
slice it down and keep the seeds in
there because i want some heat as well
and that's that
star knees that's right yeah i wouldn't
have thought i'd put that in there no no
one thing you never used to do was work
with many spices there wasn't many
chinese influences i wasn't very
adventurous with spices like me no i
like ginger do you i love ginger
especially fresh yeah coriander seeds a
little handful
tim
yeah
some soy sauce
and quite generous in soy sauce four or
five tablespoons
that helps give it that saltiness and a
nice dark rich color on the vegetables
so as it raises the meat tenderizes
quicker
i would never drink fennel and
the chilis and
that
smells lovely does that smell nice
and then a little bit of
this this is a
what's up
a rice wine vinegar is it yeah
what other tips would you give me in
order to save
money on cooking what got you through
that tough time
feeding
all six of us and
holding two jobs when that was in the
oven sea for about an hour and a half
then i would think right i'll make a
roast pudding i put an apple pie and
for the same sort of heat use the other
shelf in the oven so you weren't just
watching the pennies in terms of the
produce you also cut down the gas bill
yeah wow
super nab
yes
yeah so oxtail back on top of the
vegetables gonna top that up is that
beef stock yeah this is uh
no a really nice chicken stock why are
you putting chicken stock in it because
it's quite a sort of light fragrant way
of cooking oxtail because oxtail itself
is quite rich yeah chicken stock's nice
and light
just cover it with stock lovely colorism
a beautiful color
little taste there we go big deep breath
okay then
well that's lovely i can taste the
fennel in that is that nice that's
lovely
oh jesus
damn water for nan
[Laughter]
take some water now this is water come
on
while mum recovers from the kick off the
chili to go with my oriental influenced
oxtail i'm going to knock up a quick
fresh radish salad
take a bunch of radishes and separate
off the edible leaves
once washed thoroughly place half the
radishes in the bowl with the leaves
chop the remaining radishes in half and
add them too
[Music]
next peel and finally slice a banana
shallot
add them to the radishes and season with
salt and pepper
dress with a good squeeze of fresh lemon
juice and a drizzle of olive oil
then mix
radish salad it's that simple
next up dessert delicious poached pears
i love pizza ready so we're gonna poach
them with a little bit of chili
chili
never heard of that little bit of
saffron no
no
now pan on
take off a little slice like that so
they stand up nicely and then peel
okay then and then the chilli you hold
that up and just go down yep
through
and open that up okay into the water
seeds in as well
a little bit of chilli
water and sugar what are they holes
saffron is expensive but you only need
the tiniest little bit
a little pinch to make that water go
light and golden star in these how comes
the chinese you've like sliced it at the
end and it's not put in whole i want all
that flavor coming out of the chili
we're going to make
the most amazing star in east dust sorry
stars dust
should get your star nice in there
seed
up and then
in
see all those little seeds yeah
and then
you start grinding
a little teaspoon of ginger give it a
nice mix thank you meg and that's gonna
dust the top of the pears once they're
cooked
ryan get your pears
drop them in
[Music]
there and that's what we're going to
sprinkle
mmm
ginger and sternies wow the rice is that
very good
that's lovely isn't it so once they're
cooked cool down sprinkle that over the
top right have you guys got homework yes
see you guys come back shortly thank you
turn that down and let them pour
okay bye thank you guys bye
after an eight minute simmer our pair
should be ready now just get your knife
on put the knife through and see how
easy the knife is
so that means they're soft and cooked
now you can leave them in that overnight
two or three days all right and they
just get darker
and more beautiful
the good thing about the cooking liquor
is that you don't throw that away
because you can use that again for
re-poaching
beautiful
i mean they look impressive they smell
delicious don't they
[Music]
look at the colors nice lovely isn't it
because they're amazing
and just
smells delicious
and then take your little
star and east dust
and just
dust
over look at that nice lovely now for my
favorite part
the oxtail
wow
look at that
is beautiful
hmm
i'm just melts in your mouth doesn't it
i love the way you see that just sliding
down the bone there's no waste in that
at
all could you carry that to the table
please then yes i will do lovely and i
will grab that
that is beautiful
[Music]
this is my ultimate thrifty dinner
sumptuous slow cooked chinese braised
oxtail with a light and peppery radish
salad
followed by gorgeous chilli poached
pears with star and east dust
you